hi guys I'm Eric box and I just saw
Logan and this was really one of the
best films in the superhero genre that I
have ever seen like this is exactly the
Hugh Jackman Wolverine movie that we've
been wanting somehow topping x-men
origin what but really other than this
being a poignant emotionally powerful
redemption tale and conclusion the
Jackman portrayal of the Wolverine
character Logan hinted at a lot of
interesting theories about the x-men
universe so in this video I'm going to
quickly offer my best explanation for
those big questions and how Logan fits
into the x-men timeline and obviously a
huge spoiler warning here go watch the
movie first and then coming back here
okay first up biggest question a lot of
you have been wondering about what
happened to the x-men so throughout the
movie it's implied that pretty much all
of the old mutants have died off
specifically there's a mention of a
mysterious West Chester incident and a
radio broadcast reports the deaths of
hundreds of people and seven mutants for
gets turned off now obviously West
Chester New York is the location of
Charles Xavier Earth Institute and later
in the film
Charles confesses his guilt over
accidentally killing mutants now this
was probably the result of one of his
mass features which occurred throughout
the movie when Charles doesn't take his
meds causing everyone in the nearby
vicinity to be paralyzed unable to
breathe now Logan and Laura seem to be
able to sustain it with their
regeneration powers but Caliban mentions
that it could have killed him also
several people in that casino look
severely injured or dead and then
earlier in the film Donald Pierce says
that Charles at Caesars mind was labeled
as a weapon of mass destruction by the
government so I think that all of the
stems from this West Chester incident
when Charles suffered a massive seizure
killing seven mutants except Logan the
only one strong enough to survive it now
who were those seven mutants we may
never find out but my guess is that it's
some mix of the faces that we saw at the
end of Days of Future past like rogue
storm Hank McCoy Kitty Pryde Iceman and
maybe Scott Summers and Jean Grey but I
feel like Jean Grey would be powerful
enough to sustain it and I have another
thought about Cyclops not to bring up it
a bit but this brings me to another
question is Logan in the x-men movie
timeline so yes according to the
director
while marketing the film James Mangold
and Hugh Jackman suggested that Logan
would be
it's own solo story set in the Year 2029
not so much concerned with the
continuity of the x-men timeline like
the other movies are but technically it
does take place in the timeline as it
was reset in Days of Future past the
events of that movie in x-men apocalypse
are part of this movie's backstory so
for example at the end of the movie
Logan learns that Xander rice was the
son of a scientist whom he killed in the
alkali Lake lab which we saw an x-men
apocalypse there's also an awesome
moment when someone says to Logan I
heard you were in Phoenix you know in
Phoenix yeah I'm sure Logan is very
proud of that point in the timeline now
there are a lot of other Easter eggs
that I plan to break down in greater
depth in another video but next question
what about the other mutants one of the
big mysteries of the film is why mutants
have been dying off Pierce mentions
early on that most naturally occurring
mutants have gone extinct like the tiger
which is also apparently extinct in 2029
there's also a new saber headline that
refers to the decline of mutant birth
rates this whole movie has a children of
men vibe with a mutant fertility crisis
leading to this old man sacrificing
himself to ensure the survival of this
young generation of news and at the end
of the movie we learned what caused this
mutant extinction
Vanda ricin if company were slipping and
anti-mutant toxin into corporate food
and water supplies basically
orchestrating mutant genocide through
the stuff we consume every day in fact
this is set up earlier in the film with
Logan talking with the farmer Morrison
about how big government took over the
water line and all the nearby corn
plantations to make sugar and corn syrup
which are and pretty much everything we
and for that there's another scene that
underlines how dangerous all this
corporatization and automation are to
the little guy with the self-driving
semi trucks running Logan off the
highway so that brings me to another
question how does this all fit in with
Xander Rice's plan so Rice's goal was to
gradually wipe out all natural mutants
so that he could have a monopoly on his
own artificial weaponized mutants
created in his transition lab in Mexico
City he did that by fertilizing Mexican
women with the DNA gathered from mutants
with Logan's DNA used to make x-23 Laura
but after he
his experiments to control the children
failed rice had a breakthrough with x24
and adult clone of wolverine rice
explained in the middle of the movie
that children have to be taught rage and
loyalty whereas an adult's Wolverine
clone could just be programmed with it
and now that x24 made them unnecessary
rice had the other kids killed but the
nursing staff in the facility helps them
escape lady and rice using Pierce in the
Reavers the next 24 to hunt them down
bringing me to the next question what is
eaten and is it real so early in the
film the nurse Gabriela hires Logan to
take Maura to specific coordinates in
North Dakota but shortly after that
Logan flips through Lourdes x-men comics
and sees the same coordinates belonging
to a fictional mutant sanctuary called
Eden so at this point he assumes it's
all made up but then later on we learned
that the kids actually did use the
coordinates as a rendezvous point at
this lookout tower in North Dakota so
they're not just random coordinates they
did lead to something and we hear one of
these kids talk to someone over the
radio telling them that they've been
approved across the Canadian border they
just have to run eight miles north
through the woods so where are these
kids going exactly and who were they
talking to over the radio and is there
an actual mutant sanctuary called Eden
like the comic suggested so it seems
like the movie is saying Eden was indeed
fictional but the kids used the concept
of the Eden and the coordinates in the
comics to meet up at this outpost then
presumably they would cross the border
into Canada where rice and his men
couldn't follow them and that guy they
were talking to was probably some
friendly Canadian who was just going to
meet the north of the border to ensure
their safe passage however I have a
theory and it's kind of a stretch but
just hear me out I think that it's
possible that Eden is real and that's
where the kids are headed at the end of
the movie and maybe we'll see it in if
there's ever a sequel that follows x-23
here's where i'm coming from on this
when Mogan argues with Laura about the
comics and whether they're real he makes
a condescending reference to the writer
of the comics like they were an x-men
insider who lied about what really
happened so I think that it's possible
that the person behind the comics was
actually one of the x-men and which of
the x-men has Wolverine historically
found the most aggravating psyche
right so whether it was Cyclops or
someone else I think they might have
snuck in these coordinates into the
comics as a secret message to mutant
leading them to this outpost meeting
place and then once they arrived there
he would get in touch with them and tell
them to cross the border to get taken to
Eden a real secret place run by real
surviving mutants and those mutants
could have been the voices on the other
end of that radio call now maybe that's
how you read this already or maybe this
theory is totally bogus but I think it's
possible and it's interesting so shut up
in any way speaking of that comic book
one final big question what are the
x-men in the world of Logan I talked
about this in one my trailer breakdown
but it's kind of crazy that specific
uncanny x-men comic books show up in
this movie like I get that these heroes
would have a fan following for example
over in the MCU there are those Captain
America Trading Cards but remember those
are made for like war propaganda
purposes they were justified in the
world of the movie and those are not
nearly as meta as having the fans of the
x-men chronicle their history with
actual x-men comics and for those comics
to be the same version of the comics
that inspired all these movies and by
the way I should say that these aren't
real-life X and comics issues but Fox
did bring in the x-men artist Joe
Quesada to illustrate them so that
they'd have the same look and design so
what do these comics need and why does
another new mutant kid have a Wolverine
action figure and why did they trim his
beard to give him the classic Wolverine
mutton-chop
and why do we see Pierce keep addressing
Wolverine Charles and Caliban as this
they were former celebrities so again my
theory is that this is all the end
result of whoever created the comic
books within this universe spreading and
popularizing this distorted legend about
the x-men in order to try to keep
mutants relevant and popular among young
generation and yeah maybe to secretly
rescue mutant refugees and a side effect
of this underground comic book
propaganda campaign is that mutants like
Wolverines became pop culture figures
but unfortunately that led to two bad
consequences one since Wolverine is
recognizable it makes it that much
harder for him to try to blend in and
get around undetected whenever he tries
to stay out of trouble and two since the
mutants were more popular in the general
public instead of hunting them down or
or restricting their rights like in the
past Xander rice came up with a secret
toxin to wipe them all out which ended
up being far more lethal and effective
but really what I love about this is not
only does it create this interesting
reality for the world of the story
it brings Logan back to where x-men all
started the comics that we read and
loved as kids this was Hugh Jackman's
final performances Wolverine and it's so
fitting that we say goodbye to him as
he's surrounded by kids clutching
Wolverine toys those kids represent us
the Nerds like many of us were around
this age when we first saw Jackman play
Wolverine and even if you're older admit
it you still had that action figure and
I just love how Logan which is a
grounded gritty realistic Western still
uses x-men fan service in these targeted
ways to deliver this perfect emotional
finale
okay that covers all the big stuff and
you may have had other questions about
Logan but as I mentioned I'll be working
on another breakdown the movie so keep
an eye out for that also be sure to
check out my video about the Deadpool to
preview scene that played before the
movie and let me know what you think in
the comments and if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video to all
your friends you can also contribute to
us on patreon big thanks to all of our
current patrons especially Kenny Smith
you can hit me up on Twitter a TA box
with any thoughts or questions that you
had about Logan or follow new rockstars
on Twitter at new rockstars for updates
on our videos all right thanks for
watching bye